welcome once again to rhythm with
Griffin I'm your host Eric Griffin I'm
back here at all things comedy I know I
got my home place my home studio and
everybody you know you guys like that
but I told you I'm still gonna be here
especially when I have big guests such
as the one that I have today but so let
me start off let's start to program off
with let me introduce my today's guest
give it up for the very talented mr. ari
Spears what's up baby how y'all doing
Gary Spears in the building every Spears
I just went through that is it Ahri's or
Aries it's Airy come from you know what
man my birthday is April 3rd okay you
don't listen to my podcast I say this to
everybody go everybody always says oh
yeah I heard some clips but right I had
this thing where when I first started
I'd do different theme songs I would do
a theme song and then like you know then
people started sending me theme songs
really yeah so heam songs that were
known no no they make them these people
make this this is original music but
when you say play theme song it's a
theme song is no no no no it's the theme
song from my cell that you created yet
know these people create it we got that
figured out okay so and then they they
plan and every week I get a new one you
know you play them everything I play
every week is a new one like I say I'm
always looking for a theme song and
here's a new one and this one this is
like some of my favorite producers Eli
wintermen and Rob Kimmel these guys made
it and they're and they're I gotta say
their ban octopod is that right yeah I
think it's octopod and no no it's dope a
pod there it is dope a pod an octave cat
but they made me a great one and then
they sent me another one in and this is
it right here
[Music]
thank it is like a 80s video game no no
this is like Beverly Hills Cop 5 you
know right we in the car it's a
convertible
[Music]
80s a little bit you come right between
two to seven some of the black so I'm
the friendly non-threatening there you
go
well this once again detective design
Rob and Eli did it again
all right anyways well let me let me
just if I could first say thank you
because I stumbled up on you on
Instagram
oh really yeah I saw you know when they
will you go to the search and all the
videos I saw you there and have reached
out to you and you oblige so thank you
because I like you
and my new podcast been around for about
a year a little over a year and from
what I've been told is you need to get
on other people's podcast for your
podcast to grow yeah yeah I know it's
yeah it's a it's a greed relationship
right so thank you because I've gone out
to some people and they've said no so
the fact that you said yes be like the
Mafia make a note well you and you for
sure we're like you know you you
definitely was hounding me about it -
like yes yeah I'm a persistent my [ __ ]
yeah but you know I just like to get
[ __ ] done man
no what do you think about like in the
podcasting world right now it's like
it's not very black have you noticed
that well
nothing starts out very black and then
it becomes too black and that's when
white folks move out
you know MTV wants to put a time ago
didn't allow [ __ ] on all the shows
[ __ ] and now they're gone
well you ever they had the WB network
yeah I always thought like networks
launch themselves on the black platform
with a license true you know they would
be dead it was the WB than it was like
you know homeboys in outer space and it
was like all these black shows and now
the WB is now CW here and it's white as
hell here's the underlining whether they
use us or run away from us we're not
being used properly yeah like they we
you know at first they didn't want us
then we get in we over saturate the
market and they get the [ __ ] out or they
start wet out with us and make the money
off our backs and then go buy [ __ ]
either way welcome that's how you feel I
mean I'm going off of what histories
written mmm you know what I like to do
on the show is I like to like get
people's origin story uh-huh you know
what I mean so like were you from New
York Hell's Kitchen New York yeah
straight from New York sir now remember
now I remember you
way back in the day cuz I remember you
being on Def Jam you 16 years old right
yeah 16:1 Martin you were 16 Martin was
the host that was the heyday yeah second
year you had a second year man what it
was like
you ever look back on it now and be like
mmm no you know what a little bit but
what I really look at more is it's weird
because when you go back and look at all
those episodes from the beginning and
you see Bill Bellamy and Corey Holcomb
and myself and even Dave Chappelle it
was fun watching how raw we were cuz we
would lean on certain things like for
instance and I told bill this you know
he would say within his whole set that's
crazy right thousand times [ __ ] we would
never do today so now today we are like
John Coltrane and Miles Davis yeah even
though bill still probably has one of
the best all-time if you had to rank the
top five sets from Def Jam's history
that booty-call said I told him ain't
[ __ ] they owe you is it yeah yeah it's
the it's one of the best so many people
stole from that yeah I even do a thing
in my act right now where I'm like no
I'm sure you remember how old are you 47
okay I'm okay see I'm 40 I just turned
44 so we yeah we both know remember to
do from The Cosby Show that originated
the the Chinese dubbing voice are you
talking about Don Reed everybody stole
yeah Don I called Don Reed old-school
all right every time I seen one is to
guy I know him well I'd be like what's
up old school man the one that did it
shout out to Don who when you in LA I
got to get you on he actually does a
great one-man show in the Bay Area yeah
we're doing it he was the originator so
much thirty-one - you know how we aged
bro but yeah man Bill Bellamy and Bill
was my man coming up in Jersey in New
York East Orange peppermint lounge
Indigo blues Tribeca and like I told
bill man I said man there's been movies
merchandise and I'm a fanatic over Sex
in the City
yeah and they use the phrase so I'm just
like man
you know we're talking about just the
name just the words booty call yes yes
like he actually Patna yeah he coined it
right right yeah make enough money off
of it anything yeah that's good they
made a movie exactly that's what I'm
saying iconic yeah okay so okay so let's
start again so you you you you're in New
York yeah at what point did you know you
wanted to be a comic because you were 16
years old here well how'd you go from
knowing to like being on Def Jam at 16
um you know let me give you the cliff
notes you know my dad's era was prior my
era was Murphy I was born in 75 mutates
baby yeah yeah
he's the reason why I'm doing exactly
and I would sit up and watch him with my
dad religiously on SNL and then later on
in life I found out we had to say
birthday same astral astrological signs
oh wow
and I just took all of that as a source
of inspiration away do it yeah he
started doing comedy of 14 I did a lot
of the chitlin circuit clubs in Jersey
in New York and by the time and and you
know and I always say this to my man
people give Russell Simmons all the
credit for Def Jam
cuz his name is on the bill I right
right but if it hadn't been for bob
sumner right who was the brain he just
brought it to rust and said Russ put
your stamp on it and the rest is history
but you know he bob sumner he's the one
he's the reason that got me in to steer
me in this direction and then by the
time I was 16 I made my death my debut
on Def Jam the next year the following
the next year I did a Showtime at the
Apollo when I was 17 and then from there
man I just I moved out to LA and you got
on you had that show that is it but but
I got caught up first in what they were
doing that they don't do anymore which
is giving cats development deals right
back then if you had any minutes of
funny they signed you up David it was
like you know the draft they took you
off the market so I went five straight
years where I was with every network for
one year and it probably made just over
a million dollars with nothing to show
forth so by the time I got to Fox they
actually wanted to audition me for the
day or she actually auditioned me for
the first year of MADtv but I couldn't
do it because I was locked in a deal
with Fox with Aaron Spelling so I did
this show called crosstown
traffic which is like the Mod Squad it
came and went didn't do [ __ ] oh wow
and you know say so how many shitty
shows have you been on to my first
actual TV show was called south of
Sunset I remember he was in a good
convertible yeah you know yes like he
was like eight away yeah yeah but Glenn
Frey from the Engel from the Eagles guy
soul and that show came out we did we
didn't even air the whole season we did
one episode and was cancelled because
number one the fires were going on so we
never even aired in LA oh wow and we
were up against home improvement which
was the number one show right
also Melrose Place so we got crushed in
the ratings and because Glenn Frey had
such a horrible relationship with the
network he did everything he could to
piss them off
oh wow they said well we'll show you so
you got caught up in that got caught up
in that and by the time mad TV's third
season rolled around I still was with
Fox and the then-president peanut
churning was like a man I like this dude
we couldn't develop none for you but
[ __ ] put my man and Adam Adam Adam
Adam Fox wanted me anyway so you know
there it is so at that particular time
that when you were 16 and you were on
that Def Jam's day yes did you feel like
like where did you see your career going
at that point in my mind I had it mapped
out the same way Eddie's was mapped out
do your cop movies on a sketch show
going to my first big movie yeah but you
know and I will say this there's been so
many people online and in the streets
who tell me to this day
MADtv was way better than SNL now we may
have been but they would have big kid on
the block well it's like we were like
it's like somebody like in sonic burger
over McDonald's you know I mean it might
be better but there's more me not what
it is so you get something you when you
got on MADtv and you were on where for
like you know it seemed like forever
right hey yes yeah eight years and then
and then that shows huge I mean it's
like Bobby Lee is one of my best friends
and he like you know especially in
Canada you got your the Canada do when I
first went to Canada
it was ridiculous yeah my Will Sasso is
from Canada and we would like rock stars
out there and to show you just how vast
this [ __ ] especially with YouTube and
all the social media right the first
time I went to South Africa I [ __ ] you
not
I had a moment going from getting out of
getting off the planes are going to
baggage claim where African dude cuz I'm
big in Africa too but everything was
treating me like I was a team in the
bathroom singing coming to America you
don't understand how much I love you
when you speak the King's English no
comedy show and literally grab my hand
and smooch my [ __ ] and I'm with my [ __ ]
and I'm like might not be too much hold
with ya I'm a keen [ __ ] so it was like
you know mind-blowing yes it to notice I
had that kind of reach and it was all
from MADtv right like just like pretty
much yes they would watch that then go
watch yeah yeah you know it's funny that
you just as you just did that voice I'm
reminded that you know you were that was
like one of your things like impressions
yeah so like when did that start was
that like that was anymore if you're
watching a month when I was watching
Eddie him to mr. Rogers neighborhood
James Brown celebrity hot tub I just
always had a thing plus my mother's a
jazz and blues singer she used to open
up and perform with the great Lionel
Hampton for you young birds out there
one of the great jazz pioneers legends
of all time and she had a picture where
she sang for Reagan in the White House
so my ear for tone and inflection and
rhythm I got from her so my first
impression growing up was Louis
Armstrong cuz that's you know who my
mother father would play what I knew
they was [ __ ] the door was closed and
all dad get in they would always try to
send us to the school for haagen-dazs
ice cream and Pepsi that's great yeah
and so then you I didn't realize that
that was part of it like being a singer
yes you know so people that have an ear
for music they know tone ain't no
inflection they know riffs and rhythms I
would often hear Stevie Wonder and
certain R&B singers ago
make your voice risk your eyes it's a
talent it's an ear that you born with so
when I would hear certain people and of
course me growing up as a kid in the 80s
you know Bill Cosby see got to have the
brakes and put on the bike you know so
some of that and you know hobo chasing
us a little bit light so it's just
hearing them them inflections and
knowing how to do them and I'm gonna
tell you man who I love to do and I
don't mean to be corny and be like a
mule but I do because okay anything
anybody that's new cycle mother giving
birth to a new child knew that voice
Paul Mooney are you doing Paul Mooney
falling asleep but falling asleep I did
a show with him maybe last year in the
main room and they got him in a chair
and he's repeating jokes and he's you
know they take the mic away from him you
know you know I was at Tommy T's in
Pleasanton and Tommy's real close with
Paul's brother so he had called and and
I had heard Paul was health-wise kind of
going through it so he had called his
brother and you know I don't know if you
go through this but one thing I don't
like is ask me first before you want to
put me on the phone with somebody
oh I can't oh my god it's like they
either want you to do a performance but
sometimes you just don't feel like
talking to my [ __ ] dude you didn't
like this when your mom did it she
talked to you about right
so he called Paul's brother inside yeah
Aires does a great impression to him you
should bring Paul to the show maybe they
can get on stage together and this hi no
Paul they feel it right so at one point
he drags Paul out from the greenroom no
Jenna I can't go
I got acknowledged ladies and gentlemen
the legendary by a collapse of [ __ ] and
at one point
Paul's reaching for the mic come onstage
and I'm scared to give it to him for the
exact reason that you said first of all
you're gonna [ __ ] up the rhythm of my
show right and then if you ain't Chris
Paul is one thing to be Chris Paul do
you shake give it back I can fall right
back in pocket
but if the audience is going yeah yeah I
come clean that up yeah I don't want
that responsibility so I said in my mind
I go design nope all [ __ ] up cuz uh
Paul a sham stage with nobody in his I
got it together mind right Paul now did
you all stage but [ __ ] please
so the fact that he was and he almost
look like he was in a drunken haze the
Batman he was doing that I was like hear
this this month again right but to
relive the good Paul yeah he's here now
you gonna ask Paul the question answer
to you in his right mind
hello mr. Mooney what's going on brother
[Laughter]
what are you thinking to state a black
comedy today [ __ ] what do you think of
the state of like other they're gonna
ask me because we know what it is and I
know you likes getting a guy I know you
have white and you ask that white man to
ask that [ __ ] in you go to the state of
comedy but people to listen to my gas
won't even is that that's how that's how
long ago right to the point where his
sons are doing common well here's what's
why two people will often request me you
know what don't bang me so much could
you hear you can hear you they got to
get some shots for this that's the next
step
Aaron you know because people keep this
is people complain about this people
will often come to my show black people
and go a man do that Paul Mooney and the
promise is if I do a show where the
audience is predominantly black right
and I'm not talking about Huxtable
[ __ ] I'm time a good time yeah yeah
then that'll fly but places where I go
it's real diverse maybe a lot of white
people you don't really know who Paul is
unless you either a a die-hard comedy
fan both black and light or you some
[ __ ] yeah white folks don't really
know who Paul is and even the [ __ ]
that read don't know who Paul is don't
want to make don't want to try to move
on exactly so it's it's hard doing Paul
Mooney is not like doing Bill Cosby or
Shaquille O'Neal where that's
universally loved right right has a
certain amount of appeal Paul is a
selective taste now what do you think
about the
fact that when you were coming up and
you were doing the chitlin circuit and
you do a lot of black rooms even today I
mean do you still see like a distinct
difference between the two audiences um
yeah yeah like doing DC even though DC
and Baltimore Merlyn ain't that far the
mentality black people in DC because
it's such a metropolitan well-to-do area
I just got just got back from DC right
you know look [ __ ] [ __ ] right but
there's degrees the [ __ ] you know like
I say I say this on stage sometimes I'll
say to a white person hey you know the
difference between me and this thing
ahead with the gold in his mouth and the
sunglasses on here in the dark club I'm
the Huxtables that's good times
mm-hmm so sometimes the mentality
doesn't fit depending on the comic style
for instance I had asked the host there
whose name is Bama I said man this room
is always in 98 predominantly percent
black and some rough [ __ ] in here do
you talk about Alabama no no it's a
comic name BAM okay I know another comic
no I'm saying no I can't another comic
named Alabama oh yeah but you're
shortening his name no it might be
Alabama oh Jessica refrigerator yeah
yeah got long dredge I say y'all ever
get any white artists in here who's
filled this room out he said yeah twice
we got Tom green and Tom Arnold and the
mornings was predominately white he was
like yeah cuz Harley you ever see any
white people in there so he goes I'm
talking about the comedy factory the
boss yes I've done the bottom so you
know yes when I first did the Baltimore
comedy factory when they used to do it
above the deli and it was like you did a
Thursday night and my three shows Friday
three show Saturday my thing would be
one of the shows would be white one of
the shows would be mixed with like
country folks and then there would be a
Def Jam show you know all of its Def Jam
there for you no no no I'm tell you for
me the reason why we do it the hell I
haven't done it excited and I do I just
did my boobies okay cuz comedy fact that
keeps moving around
right well the last location they were
at before this current one was right at
the power plant so when you where was
the old improv before the right but they
they've actually moved to a different
location that you probably haven't been
there since the sister the shooting or
whatever happened and right I don't it
was a stabbing yeah that's interesting
right but it was when your weekend right
didn't sand the police station is down
the street right right but but let me go
back to so anyway we were talking about
the racial mix up right what I'm trying
to say and he said it goes well you know
there's some brothers that come here to
just they don't do well I said who's
dumb on Gerrard Carmichael and I go I
could see that and this is no slight to
Gerard but as I'm saying some [ __ ]
audience wise are equipped to play chess
but them [ __ ] equipped for chutes and
ladders over there Carmichael is alone
what's the word I'm looking for us
sadiddy' my best friend's far away so he
don't give you that energy that
sometimes them but they're looking for
yeah yeah and they want that fast food
food
yes but I'm noticing like so are you
seeing is now you draw on that crowd is
it you just drawing that crowd um like
when you go other places other than you
are like are like the black folks you
know how the good times folks coming to
see you I draw [ __ ] it right but I
also drive draw drug dealers - yeah you
know I you know and this is not me in
any way to my own horn but because I
grew up such a fan of Eddie Murphy and
Pryor and I studied those guys and I
Dave Chappelle I love it when that
audience is the mixture of all of
everything I'm hardcore not hardcore
white black it's more fun that way for
me yeah I think the best ratio of an
audience is like when it's half white
right okay and then there's enough black
people that they're not scaring these
white people but they feel like they're
a part of what the black people are
laughing at well you wanna say yeah but
but I also think even if that's even if
that's not the makeup what what is what
is a you know testament to a comet's
brilliance is if the material despite
all that right I can brought them
together and make them see what you want
them to see you know I'm saying there
are some comics who simply cannot do
that like I remember one time I just got
back from a gig and I'm at baggage claim
and it's me Alex Thomas and Joe Torre
and we were talking about comedy clubs
we like and I was like man I'm cooling
on Atlanta because dim [ __ ] out there
is just too and he was telling me and he
it was funny he was like you know I told
the promoter the guy that is suck my
dick
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] this [ __ ] that and
Paul bird stereotypical [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's a night for him yeah yeah but
you can't put him in front of me and
this [ __ ] wrapping up a set time on
and that's how you eat corn on a [ __ ]
booty hole you ready for your headlining
to come out talk about my trip to France
yeah dude you talk about the Atlanta
Comedy Theatre oh okay okay check this
out I just did the Atlanta Comedy
Theatre maybe like six months ago right
I know the owner I didn't realize that
this was just the what was though used
to be called what was your partner
uptown uptown I didn't know or I would
have said no Atlanta Comedy Theatre
sounds like it's a nice you know let me
stop it cuz I want to ask you I think I
know where you're going cuz they move
locations yeah so have you done the most
current one yeah where they got the
throne chair to Game of Thrones chair
off to the side for people to take
pictures in no I haven't seen their
cordless mic with the metal all over the
ceiling it looks like it's in like a
little strip mall you know think so yeah
this is it I don't remember all that
stuff because I was already so like
taken aback by first of all first of all
luckily they had two green rooms okay
okay so I'm in one right and I make
myself very unapproachable like I'm in
here well you all can go and so the
other green room is like apparently
every comic in LA that's right every
comic in Atlanta is in this green room
about to do a guest set right I'm not
asked nobody says hey can such as I do a
guest that nobody asked me the headliner
of the [ __ ] show nope
hey I'm uh
yeah we doing get set and then the DJ
want to play like a whole you don't want
to just play a song he want to say hey
man what biggie album you want to come
out right right so this show starts
extremely late unlike the white clubs
and again I even said to my feet I go
are we the stars or to DJ cuz this thing
is doing his mixtape thinking did he's
in the audience and even worse is like
the the MC who it's like like they
coming across like it's actually their
night you know it's like their night and
here the emcee and then like you know
you're in there okay but here's the
thing
I might people did like me they watch
workaholics and I'm dying up here in
like so I'm talking about there's white
people and Asians and he came to that
club right so when I get on stage I look
at their faces and I had to go like this
hey I didn't know it was this black
either just like just a disarm right you
know I mean for the people that don't
really know the insides and outs of
comedy this is why this is refreshing to
me because I have a reputation in this
business and amongst the comedy
community of being an [ __ ] part of
the reason this comes is because I'm
aloof I don't hang around a lot of
people I don't like doing jazz hands
I'm a quiet [ __ ] and I stick to
myself aloof is often perceived as
[ __ ] just cuz I don't come talk to
you or smile it doesn't mean I think I'm
better than you it doesn't mean I'm
trying to be an [ __ ]
this is just who I am when I'm not
performing I'm a quiet my [ __ ] right
right and also because I've done look
again I've been doing this for 30 years
which means in my mind at least I've
earned a certain amount of stripes so if
I'm the headliner it's my show like it
would be any other body any other
headline right if I want to bring a
white feature because I've had black
features and 25 minutes are you doing
black-white comedy then me doing 30
minutes of black-white comedy it's too
much so I'm not even saying you can't do
race humor but I don't want to bombard
my audience especially if it's
mixed with white people oh this is funny
but Jesus they're beating us up yeah
it's like spoken word poetry exactly
like a certain amount of diversity yeah
yeah yeah that's perceived and has been
said to me when I come to the local city
I'm in yeah all the comics yeah anything
I don't like [ __ ] on his show they
don't like his own people mm-hmm
what a [ __ ] why not like my own people
we do everything well
I mean so of course I love my own people
but in terms of the business I'm in and
I know how this [ __ ] goes I'm gonna do
what's most comfortable for me and
anybody in a right mind and in that
position would follow suit and if you if
you tell me you wouldn't you lyin
yeah and sometimes you get to places
like that particular place right and
it's just like you know I so I mean
people would think that I'm an [ __ ]
then cuz I'm very much like I remember
even check this out I remember I did
lanta improv right back in the day they
they're not there anymore but I go I
walk into the green room after the show
and there's literally 12 comics in the
green room so I said this oh this is
great
can you guys go get 10 more people you
know and then that everybody even catch
it yo yeah cuz everybody cleared out you
know but then it's like her group is
after like alright I don't get fun right
walk and here's the thing you know I
used to give a [ __ ] like I would before
they move the Houston Improv to where it
is now when it used to be a some sort of
restaurant some planet jungle [ __ ] one
day I walked in there there was eight
[ __ ] in there it's like did you I hate
when people put you in a position to be
that guy yeah and I'm just like well it
is my show and I want to be comfortable
before the show yeah then II want to
talk to anyway in Atlanta at their
comedy at the way that a comedy theater
I experience a lot of comics asking me
like they want they want to learn how
like learn [ __ ] right you know it's like
I'm not just
I'm doing a show I'm not doing a
symposium you know I'm just like the Big
Brother program right right right right
right you know and I don't know you like
that
and I tell people all the time I was
like look man after a show I go
somewhere you mean you want to chop it
up you want to talk about the game from
last night you want to talk about
whatever I talk with you I get a beer
and converse with you and don't
- no you from Adam but don't interview
me like when you first started doing
when you let me do a podcast just pull
out a mic okay now let's get to this
yeah you should wipe my sweat yeah okay
now you have a reputation for being an
[ __ ] okay but I'm just gonna tell you
some of the things I've heard you can be
a [ __ ] tell me what you've heard it
will confirm them okay see that I got
that's dangerous okay with show business
people go off of what they hear let's
just dead of self investigating we this
is the investigation we confirm them
right now horses before we die they're
not based on what you've gotten this far
mm-hmm do you sense that I sense from
text messages from you trying to get on
the show I says that it's like a 50/50
we're like you're you're an aggressive
dude you want things a certain way you
want it to happen a certain time and
like you know and not having say a
personal relationship with someone and
they don't know you like that it might
come across as harsh
it might come across as like arrogant
like you said have you even said to me
yeah it could come across like that okay
come across like that but like because
like I've heard things like you know
people got horror stories you know you
get into that you get into the GM's car
or you get into the car to go and
they're driving they're like oh yeah Wow
yeah we had yeah Harry Spears was here
like you know and he held at me or like
you know I might have the other that's
you I'm not doing hey man I got no
peanut butter in my dressing room why
I'm not getting that but you but don't
you have something your Ryder but you
want to be in a black car and if it's
not a black car you've yelled at people
for not having a black car but this is
we're confirming these are stories that
are out there man let me tell you
something yeah and I'm not you know
spitting on from what I've heard Eddie
Griffin has to have oh yeah a pair of
Air Force one sneakers so he can't be
the standard like I hear but that what
I'm saying is I'm so low maintenance
[ __ ] it's shocking
comparison to zoo the only thing I don't
even really have a writer I asked for
water mm-hmm
and that's pretty much it when I do when
I do concert shows [ __ ] be like hey I
want a tray hot chicken some salmon some
exotic bird that lives in a place you've
never heard of I want five bottles of
liquor so you feel like you're getting a
bad rap absolutely all I ask for is
water
maybe tea for my throat but other than
that no man I'm so low maintenance and
I'll have club owners and managers say
to me god you're easy yeah you know it's
just one of these things you know it's
like we never get to comics never get to
headliners don't hang out with each
other because we already doing other
clubs right let me know what else you've
heard I love behind you
your boy Bobby has probably told you
some [ __ ] he might have some stories I
asked him about it but you uh you you've
just I've just heard a lot of like give
me one give me someone you you have been
difficult on the road what does that
mean what like you yeah just like your
approach to people like how you you you
you might raise your voice to quite a
few people you know I mean right like is
this like is this what you have to say
about this is we you tonight but he's
self-refer
okay yeah you know a lot of these
[ __ ] in his business manager
wise Club wise promoter wise shady okay
I totally agree okay let me tell your
story behind but where I've raised my
voice okay I'm with you on that right
what am I only pushback on that is you
know just because somebody is shady
right it doesn't if you respond with
shady you still Shady
how am i responding with you know I'm
just saying I got you or however you
respond right it can't there's levels
right my mother once told me if you
tired of people [ __ ] you pull your
pants up
so for a long time man I knew I was
being [ __ ] I didn't know the business
well enough to know how to finagle it
how to handle it and everything I've
learned I've learned on my own I'm the
most successful person in my family
ain't nobody been to college hey nobody
ever had an extra comma on a yearly
check so I am the Michael Jackson of the
family so it wasn't like I had somebody
to put me under the wing ago hey young
fella let me show you how to maneuver
and what to do and this is a [ __ ] up
field to be in
to learn [ __ ] yes being young so I was
at a club one of the Improv in the Ohio
area and the manager there was
shortchanging me on my money and I knew
it so yeah I was upset about it and I
said something to the point of amen if
you not gonna handle my money right then
you need to holler my agent or I'm never
coming back here that turned into he
said you gonna have an angry [ __ ] on
your hands punch the wall and scared my
white delicate female circle when did
that happen
probably four times before I you know
four times ago I've been this club five
times so baby about four times ago yeah
I'm just gonna say cuz in this day and
age you can't even you know write you
came from wink at somebody right now
without it be turning into a thing well
you know so so things get exaggerated I
got you you know what I mean you're
saying very absolutely very it's so
funny because I will hear people who
come to my shows say things like yo one
of the most coolest humble down-to-earth
[ __ ] so many comics from TV and
film they come to the club they hide out
in the green green room all night when
the show's over they don't do no me
greet they just come and they feel like
you just come into my city do it then
get your money a bounce you will find me
on that barstool amongst the people I
hate the green room personally I like a
bounce in a cage I like to observe the
defense and see who in the crowd okay
look at what he ran over there this
[ __ ] ain't got no business
that hat on this [ __ ] drunk so if
there's a problem I got to know how to
attack that's who I am
I'm gonna show so and as long as you
approach me with respect and don't talk
sideways to me man
hug me man what's up man I got a suit
the [ __ ] I am
I have a short tolerance for this
business because this business is [ __ ]
up
so because of that and your past
experiences with these kind of things so
then maybe you're you have a shorter
fuse than most I wouldn't say I have a
shorter fuse because that would say that
to some degree I can't control myself
you know what I'm saying even when I'm
when I'm feeling how I'm feeling it's
always methodical it's always with some
thinking behind it because I know that
I've put myself in positions in the past
where even when I knew I wasn't wrong
that's not how the story came out right
right right
and and that stuff either stays with you
or comes up at the wrong time and [ __ ]
you so I am on my Magic Johnson tour
right now where everywhere I go is
specially in front of white folks I'm
not selling out but my grin is from
Temple to Temple Joker
I'm doing everything short of hello my
baby hello my remember had lunch with
Chris Rock dinner with Chris Rock one
time because I was really trying to get
him to produce something I wanted to do
and at the end of the meeting he just
goes to me hey man I can is off you're
three things of advice one stay funny
write as much as you can and try not to
piss these white folks off so wait how
you doing two out of three baby I'm
getting better I'm getting better
three out of three all right all right
all right yes I can tell you you I could
tell you feel something about how people
feel about you and I've Kentucky teller
that bothers you
well I would like to not give a [ __ ]
mm-hmm as most people that aren't in
show business would advise you to do
right don't give a [ __ ] B you do you
again I'm and a lot of my supporters go
man one thing we love about you
you so [ __ ] real you young soften
your material you remind us of old
school comedy do you it reminds me of
Dave Chappelle's when keeping it real
goes wrong I've been doing me for a long
time sometimes it goes wrong I'm
starting to get rid of ask the devil
what's the going rate on a soul maybe
you just misplaced yours you put your
keys I wanna know I gave it up I just
dis business man I don't like this
business I always tell people show
business until you get to the elite
level Chris Rock know and even they are
even I'm sure they'd do it if they were
if Chris Rock Kevin Hart Chappelle
Denzel Will Smith they were all sitting
at a Denny's together at a table at
their level I'm sure that they can find
things to complain about well we all can
find things to complain about but all
I'm saying is that when you act that
level where you making 20 million a film
you box office business this struggle
ain't really a struggle yeah you find
something to complain about but in
comparison to I know you explain you
complaining about your private jet
company what a great complaint I'm just
saying like I always tell people this
business is like eating real crab the
kind with the newspaper in the hammer
you got a bus to Allah but it's so
[ __ ] sweet like Chris Rock had the
best saying he goes the the worst job in
show business it's better than the best
job out of it yeah so always said [ __ ]
I will quit if I have to play the
Nickelodeon TV dad with child can
laughter right but I would never know
but I would imagine that doing that
versus something outside of show
business but then again I don't know
because my whole thing is when you when
you have the moments where you get to
live the life the red carpets the
adoration the
oh we love you and all of this and and
go to the Hollywood function it's
there's nothing like it
this [ __ ] nothing like this it's
sweet but the [ __ ] you gotta put up
with to get that piece of it'll drive
you crazy man
it'll drive you [ __ ] crazy now again
like you said once you become to Kevin
Hart's and the Chris Rock's yeah you
complaining about you jet but by that
time everything else is yeah but
sometimes people you lose perspective
because your circumstances well yeah I
think you can but I think if you can
find a way not to who wouldn't want to
enjoy that life yeah whoo it's
intoxicating who wouldn't want you know
we'll have that well okay yeah you're
misunderstood Sol and you've been doing
it a long time right and it's like you
know we get me down in this business all
right
so what are some of your highlights then
like what are some of the things that
you look back and you go oh man lead I
so glad I did this oh I don't regret
having done MADtv cuz if I hadn't it
wouldn't you know I'd be a lot less
famous than I am or successful than I am
and and and again so how man TV is
obviously a huge highlight yeah because
because particularly season they really
like I was on fire on season from
seasons three till about six we were a
well-oiled machine yeah and and and that
that ability to play off each other it's
like you know being in sports and
playing with your teammates and you get
better cuz they make you better and
you'd learn [ __ ] so comedy and timing
now again in perspective SNL is the NFL
we were more like the CFL yeah so it's a
little frustrating because I always felt
like and let me go to boxing terms
there's the people's champion and
there's the paper champ yeah you would
love to be both right but some boxes on
paper on a [ __ ] but the fans couldn't
give a damn and then vice versa
the fans love you but the boxing the
powers that be on paper yeah so I've
always been I feel the People's Champ
these streets love me these mofos
everywhere I go black why I was took my
daughter to Red Lobster today for a
birthday for lunch she loves her lobster
and this middle-aged white woman did
look like she wouldn't
say hello to me and if you're too I like
you a clutch your what the cell phone
and I hand not even see I approach me
she put a hand on my shoulder wait yeah
comedy special Hollywood look I'm
smiling we love you we miss you okay and
then like I say everywhere I go from
different walks of life black white
asian Hispanic old young gay straight
they do everything and I'm pleased me
I'm not bragging I'm not tryin to be
conceited but they do this [ __ ] yo you
wanted to goats
one of the legends you've been doing
this for 30 years [ __ ] your body of
work on man TV ridiculous your shacks
all start coming ridiculous your last
special Hollywood look I'm smile
ridiculous [ __ ] that know me your Vlad
TV interviews how real you kept it about
racism and about Hollywood people love
that because that's in short supply
mmm-hmm as we're all trying to be moist
now with comedy and not offend and not
stand our ground Floridian with my [ __ ]
I stand my ground I'm not moving I'm
like Jordan Belfort and uh wolf of Wall
Street I'm not [ __ ] later
[ __ ] I'm not leavin again this is what
I know this is what I bleed and this is
what motivates me Patrice O'Neal God
rest his soul
yeah baddest [ __ ] to me to ever
pick up a mic next to Dave Chappelle
yeah he was he was uh he was flame but
he's he was a conspiracy theorist I've
never been a big conspiracy theorist and
that's part of probably what got him in
a lot of people she's well you said I'm
gonna be in outside the Comedy Store and
he just started talking about something
you know you'd be surprised when he
knows something like yeah yeah he was on
that thing and you have a thing about it
right you know yo that [ __ ] would burn
a bridge while he's walking on it with
some Indiana Jones [ __ ]
and that kind of honesty that kind of
like and I said I've seen you perform at
the Laugh Factory and I've seen you get
it matter of fact my ex-wife was with me
at the time was my wife when you had her
in tears that feeling when you're a
comic and you look into the crowd and
you see my [ __ ] glasses doing this
dude in an alabama one time tell me like
[ __ ]
my favorite compliment from my it was
atlanta comrade eater a middle-aged
black man after my city walk to me he
said like this poignant set brother
poignant sounds the word and i knew
exactly what he meant exactly shook my
hand strong too poignant sick brother
poignant you know and i think he was
like saying like I'm so glad to see that
here that's the vibe I got from that's
exactly what he was saying yes when I
hate when I hear people come up to me
and go and anybody can say look you're
funny a funniest subjective so even if
you think carrot top is whatever there's
somebody out there that has his poster
on a wall yeah he works hard yeah yeah
so I'm not trying to say we don't
appreciate funny Leah tell me how funny
I am I love it but every now and then I
go and you're intelligent
yeah something dull did a good cop you
mean because funny made me think right
cuz cuz it means not only am i coming in
here showing you I can slug [ __ ] but I
know how to box
I know how to make you think I got some
more whip and whap to my game other than
just trying to be Tyson to take your
[ __ ] head off
now many comets possess all of those
abilities I think that I remember the
first time I did tripping on Tuesday in
the comedy store main role play I
remember the first time I did it did to
show and I did it because the Dave
Arnold and Chris Spencer just happened
we were doing the Laugh Factory out in
the casino remember the that ghetto room
the day I have no idea but it was the
worst
combat
comedy like just a perfect framework its
combat calming and just like you know
did the security is in the room but
they're not in today the only way they
only gonna do something and case some
[ __ ] jump right right but anything I
remember they saw me and that was the
first time they that because you don't
normally watch other comics yeah but if
you happen to and you go see this guy's
face and they watch but they we were all
laughing about it afterwards and then
they told you you know who was running
the show say hey put me up so he put me
up on the main room and I hadn't done a
black like an all-black audience crowd
like a real show in awhile when I did
this this years ago because I just had
so many bad experiences you know what I
mean but I realize and I get the sense
Eric from watching you for having seen
you do stand-up and and you look a
little bit different I'm racially
ambiguous okay there you go
and I'm not saying you can't because I
haven't seen you in those rooms but even
myself like them rooms with you know
these go teeth three chains dirty long
fingernails you can tell these things
you know they got some dirt on them they
wouldn't take to you as quickly as
that's exactly the situation that I was
normally in before right but what I
found now and later in life being like I
have to do in comedy for so long that I
realized that it just really doesn't
even matter you know because for me like
I'm big on stage sometimes I'm animated
and I think that that's what connects to
some of those type of black audiences
right at the same time you got this guy
that's gonna come up and be like yeah
you finally do saying something poignant
you know but after I remember I did my
set kill I killed that night my main
room but that's not even really like
black you know cuz it half the room got
headshots you know I mean so it's like
lets me but you want you in Hollywood
let's not call this a black room right
right right this is like my Hollywood
black room but anyway I saw this black
comic came to me like a couple days
later and he came to me hey man but it's
like I was like oh here we go
you know I mean I saw you and you know
man I'm doing your bill set you know
what he said to me he said he said and
then he said but then I started you know
oh are the night before and you did the
same set in front
all those black people how'd you do that
cuz it's a black comic huh okay as I
thought he was some [ __ ] and I thought
to myself that's when I knew I was like
I was gonna be fine mine you know
because it was like whatever I do you
know it might be heightened mm-hm you
know when you're performing when people
want more of like what are you because I
think black rooms are more about what
you do not necessarily about what you
say you know how you say it you know to
me more I think it's a little bit of
that to go yeah you know I mean if you
talk if you're talking about [ __ ] that
you just know is beyond the area code
you have to be able to comprehend
somebody's [ __ ] in order to flow with it
yeah yeah yeah you know I'm sure though
I want to ask you a question now cuz
because me and my podcast partner Andy
Steinberg we talked about this a little
bit and when I and I'm thinking about
the Baltimore comedy club you know the
white comedians in this business that
whose names carry weight
Seinfeld louis c.k and i remember Louis
even I even heard it on YouTube he did a
funny story about having performed both
at chocolate sundaes and mo bettah
Mondays and the difference and it was a
racial thing and my question to you is
this in my mind all the greatest
comedians have the ability through their
material being so good to translate
color mm-hmm they bring they make
everybody see it can you truly call
yourself a great comic if what you do
can't be done in both rooms cuz cuz as
funny as Seinfeld is and I think he's
one of the best cuz there's a comment we
have an appetite for everything but I
question could he do a mo better Mondays
or chocolate Tuesdays and crushed the
same way you know what I think that he
could and the reason is is because
here's what I find I find that black
first of all the black audience is just
as scared of you as you are of them okay
and they and they are cuz I cuz I highly
know if I buy that no dude the moment I
found that the moment you cried back
it's a date they already like in and of
itself is its own skills right right
right right I get that but I'm saying
the moment you take charge of the room
and I think somebody that's a wordsmith
that allows themselves to have the
energy to be able to like this is my
point from beginning to end these people
because first of all my problem with
with a black comedy is that the comics
themself don't respect the black
audience enough they don't respect it's
just like the that movie did you say to
black okay I didn't see that
oh [ __ ] jay-z's in his office not talk
to these young rap okay yeah and he's
young rappers are like he jay-z's like
why y'all rapping about that stuff he
got we we got to you know they we have
to rap about this stuff it ain't gonna
listen to us and and and I said comedies
the same way you don't have to talk
about these things that like you're
talking about like if a black comments
coming up before you talking about the
differences with race and that you don't
necessarily have to talk about those
things right you know you don't have to
be whatever uses with the stereotype of
a black comic is to win over the crowd
and so I think that a high-level comic
with a high level IQ about what they're
talking about
they're gonna do fine it's not gonna
it's gonna be different it might not be
belly laughs rhythm is gonna be
different I think it could be
appreciated and the fact that people
think that the black audience can't
appreciate cerebral comedy to me is the
part of the problem yeah I think I'm
split on that I think I think some black
people are equipped to deal with it but
some distinct you mean white comics
you're saying yes so I'm just ain't
again going back to the Jerrod
Carmichael jar I don't think that Jerrod
Carmichael Carmichael's blackness should
ever be in question
I think he's 100% power to the people as
he is but his thinking level and his
skill level and his delivery and his
cadence
might be a little too slow for [ __ ]
dis you know but he's clever but here's
the thing that I know about Jerrod being
so close to him he that it's all by
choice
you know his choice yes his choice like
he he could he could what do you want to
say blacken it up or he could make that
a shift because you know you
you you talk differently in front of
different types of people you know if
you had a funeral you even if you're
gonna tell a joke at a eulogy to make
give some levity to the situation right
it's gonna come across differently
there's gonna come arsenic in a comedy
club we're doing a corporate gig it's
different when you if you're doing a
church gig it's different you're gonna
change your thing so for his thing his
choice is I'm not gonna do Church gigs
cuz I don't want to change what I do
right but it's not to say that he can't
you know I just think that that's I know
what you're talking about there are some
comics I see them and I go I don't think
this person is ever gonna be able to
make the switch in the same way that I
see some like sort of like real ghetto
ass black comics they want to go to the
improv on a Friday night at 8 o'clock
and make these white people laugh and
they feel that they can mmm I mean I
think it's the same kind of thing you
know when you have people like
uncomfortable they looking at you like
I'm gonna get do you don't get them less
yeah sometimes I think that less than
the comedy but I just think that they're
not going to all of their skill sets I
think that they're not taking the time
to really like oh I need to do more
right I need to like not because not
everybody feels they have to some people
get comfortable right there's a lot of
money to be made in the black market
there's there's comics out there that we
know that like I never see do you know
would be on evening at the improv or you
know what I'm trying to say this Arnez J
and these types of people out there that
are just like you know back flipping all
over the place and like you know their
dude they're doing well in the black in
the black audience you know I mean but
do those people translate over to the
white audience do they want to can a but
that doesn't mean that they can't if
given the opportunity rise to the
challenge well I think that's what I
would like to see it though because
otherwise you're just guessing you know
when you look at a louis c.k and a
Seinfeld and you know how great they are
you could say to yourself there's no way
they couldn't but so you don't think
Louie can perform in front of a black
crowd if he was like if it was like I
think just on a regular night he walks
in you think that this was this was
gonna get stumped this is what was so
great about the story he told and mo
bettah Monday's is way mo [ __ ] yes
contact Charlie Sundays so he would
always de-rate fall to the way he just
sleep
[ __ ] a sec to show up his next book you
know the way you bring you up like I
wouldn't want him to introduce me to
somebody on a date Quran would be like
you know you live with his mom in a job
like that so Louie tells the story and
he goes pretty relatively well at
chocolate sundaes and he goes yeah I
went up on mo better Monday and I
remember I did the joke and I did the
punchline and there was nothing and I
could literally feel where the black
people in the crowd like oh [ __ ] that
was it so I think like this anybody
that's really great take take take
sometime after about three or four sets
he'll figure it out yeah just off the
cuff I don't know bro yeah but I've even
seen like look I've seen Chris Rock
coming to the O R in The Comedy Store
you know he just he's just coming in
because he's working on something right
immediately he comes in no expectations
you know but he goes on the cross
doesn't he know I've seen him like just
he's working it out I've seen him
working out some when he was preparing
for his Oscar thing and he was just
working it out he was moment to be like
haha but it wasn't like you were like oh
my god cuz I'm just working it out so
I'm just saying you know give me like if
we're doing a contest if this was gonna
be on NBC and they were like all right
you know this is how they should have
done last Comic Standing
you know I mean we're like you know all
right yes all black audience tonight you
know you don't really you get out there
then we're doing it like that then I
would be far more interesting we'd see
how it would go yeah I mean we would see
how we go but I just think from doing
Baltimore comedy factory when I first
started doing it that was something that
I experienced was like one night because
I would I would promote the show on a
rock show so there would be like a lot
of white people in some of the shows
yeah for the reason why the guy was
bringing me to the club twice a year is
because I drew a lot of white people in
one show like literally the whole shells
right and then and then the student Late
Show is all black like I was so thrown
aback by it like I went out on stage and
I was like oh [ __ ] this is I was like
okay
this Def Jam all of a sudden like that
really it was really like a jarring
thing because I just did three I'm doing
three show this is the third show I just
did a show like there was some like sort
of rednecks in a second show I remember
you know and now I'm doing like this is
like an it you know the chicken wings is
flying in and everybody's okay you know
and you you become like I become a
chameleon I'll be coming I got a like
okay like you know it's you you adjust
you know III would say on stage
sometimes I would go especially when I
would do a room where before I started
bringing a feature with me regularly and
they would provide the features like
local white boy or whatever and it's my
the local wife would let me take
terribly and I'm not [ __ ] on a
comedian but I'm pointing out something
I notice which is and I'd say this on
stage why people y'all applaud effort
like if a comic come up and don't really
say none funny but he put a lot of work
in the joke you could tell there was a
lot of he'll he laced it with a lot of
profanity or he exuded a lot of energy
white people will simultaneous go woo
[ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] about effort we
want results I disagree with you really
yes there are more standing ovations in
a black room than any room but you have
to earn that black people they just
standing up the most I think the most
loving and they're there they're they
are bipolar audience - black audience it
is a bipolar audience you get the
highest highs and the lowest lows but
they are they are ready to love black
audience is the most loving art did you
ever do a Comedy Central Presents no I
did half it was called a half well same
thing I don't know when I did my Comedy
Central Presents and even when I was
watching Comedy Central Presents before
I did mine
one thing I hated about it was I said
this gives comics who are just okay a
false sense of hope because they're
geared they make the audience applaud
break during certain parts that you said
are they stop doing that well this is
what I'm saying no but they used to make
the audience
room at the certain joke and I'm going
dad jokes not funny enough for that and
you're making comics who aren't great go
yeah an applause break is something you
have to earn to make my [ __ ] go oh
[ __ ]
without an applause sign or being you
know made to do that I would say to you
I understand that you that I understand
where you're coming from with that but
I've been in these rooms you're talking
about and I don't think that it's
deserving of that of an applause break
yes I don't think it's deserving of like
some of the response that you get you
know like I've seen like it sometimes
the crowd looks like they paraplegic
dancing you know anybody's so excited
about what was just said it's like for
instance when I look back on Def Jam
when I look back on some of the early
Def Jam and I see and you hear some of
the jokes that were being said that made
people go crazy it don't stand up today
well we'll listen listen but then that
leans on the subjective thing yeah I get
if an entire audience does that without
being told to do that when I'm being
prodded well then that's what it is but
when you make audience go oh [ __ ]
applause ah well that's false but the
thing about it is we I think you're
forgetting in that situation is that
they're making a television show I know
that nobody still doesn't erase the fact
that you're giving someone of nobody's
gonna gonna be on stage get an applause
break as a television show and not walk
away from that thinking I didn't do that
it was just a television show but I
don't feed your ego yeah but I would
venture they're not picking people off
the street to give a half hour to know
so like whatever they did to earn that
half hour however it's put together I'm
fine with it
because that's like whatever you've done
to be a part of the race fine but don't
give everybody trophies
I give them [ __ ] trophies who
won yeah but this isn't this is this
isn't this isn't that the trophy I mean
it's like they did the race this is the
award ceremony that's what the special
is at that point it's just an award
ceremony man now this [ __ ] to make me
feel come off like a [ __ ]
you know it would have been a snow if
you woulda came in the door be like wow
I just wanna because this is the kind of
[ __ ] I say and to me I don't want to
come in here with you or anybody else
and give the faith and we having a real
conversation when you say [ __ ] that
might not be be the politically correct
or you know goes against the grain
people perceive this as [ __ ] ISM no I
think that it's like I think I think
having pride in the job and having a
pride in like our art form there's
nothing wrong with that okay and I feel
that that's where you're coming from you
know what I mean because I get it too
because we've all looked at like where
we go we look at things and go how the
[ __ ] did that do get a special right I
mean that's just every comic does right
I'm glad you're saying that yes
most people would deny that oh no
especially now no no it's not even this
is this is filtering into regular people
don't know if you watch Family Guy oh
love it okay did you see the episode
where like Peter is like oh they're
making fun of Netflix specials not a big
fan it's so funny it's like and then
brian says to him Peter you're actually
filming your stand-up special right now
I didn't know the living room opens up
and it's a crowd I mean Netflix has made
it where everybody has a special it's
like a lot of like 15-minute specials
eight-minute special they're gonna do
like 100 two-minute special eventually
you know right so they've diluted the
market so what we're talking about is
like because we come from an era where
the word special meant something right
so take that out but like listen when I
did my half hour I felt like they did it
wrong I felt like there should be two
shows set us up to succeed do two shows
I did it with a little rel at the time
and I thought that they set him up for
failure that night because the eight
black people in Boston who came because
we did it in Boston who came to the show
for him and all these white people who
loved workaholics you know I mean so I
went up first before him and it was just
like you know hey you know I'm just like
this isn't they didn't do this right
they didn't say they didn't get the best
from
haven't you ever seen somebody you think
is really funny do a TV set then you go
what happened right well what I know
from doing TV sets now that it's not
necessarily the comics fault
Oh we'll listen do that from what I've
heard
never done one but from what I've heard
trying to do it tonight show or do let's
stand up on them late-night shows they
butcher your [ __ ] down - why am I even
doing this yeah so yeah but that's a
skill yeah the same way that you're
talking about in the same way that
you're talking about people have to
adjust to do white rooms black rooms to
me you also have to adjust to what is it
to do a television set you right fair
enough
you know but you know one of the
funniest Clips ever puts Rhys O'Neal and
it's Patrice forget the other comics
name but Opie and Anthony and they're
talking about handicapped comics of some
sort and I forget she was real popular
back in the 80s I think female and
before they even play her clip talking
about how terrible she is and at one
point they play her material and she
goes I got the clap one and the clap off
it's the same when my equipment is
better than I do
there's a pause and Patrice just goes
this [ __ ] stinks man I'm not trying to
be mean but I am working on I'm waiting
for fame to call me and this [ __ ] is
getting off with this terrible material
now again I think everybody to some
degree wishes they could be that Patrice
it wasn't always right yeah this wasn't
always good no I mean no like you know
but but the part that I'm taking from it
is that how can a guy or anyone be that
goddamn funny that goddamn good and not
did they just do no no he burned a lot
of bridges okay that you just answered
the question
okay well think of it like this - then
there are people in the NBA people get
to the NBA because they have tremendous
talent right they are they are they won
the genetic lottery right and they have
tremendous talent and they're out here
in the NBA there's not everybody that
fulfills their potential this is a
privilege it's not a right so just
because somebody is hilarious like
Patrice or many people that we know
right we all know a goat we all know who
somebody is like I wish more people knew
who this dude is but they don't also
need to have business savvy they need to
know that they need to cultivate
relationships they need to know that
they need to you know work on how to
perform in front of different types of
people they need to know that like when
keeping it real goes wrong right they
need to know that those is also part of
the business if this was just about
being funny then how many people would
be doing it well then maybe that's what
my skills need to sharpen up cristal the
[ __ ] Patrice and I and everything you
just said what Chris said there it is
that's the peanut butter and jelly but
it pains me to hear it because I'm just
goes it ain't about the jokes it ain't
about the jokes we're in the business
jokes ain't we are we all show business
my money this is a this is an
entertainment business this is what I'm
trying to tell you whether the reason
why they make people clap at those
things cuz it's a television show where
they have to sell ad revenue like you
you are you coming across like no you as
the audience watching at home are you
fooled by that so sometimes they are
sometimes they're at home just like oh I
enjoyed that you know I always tell
people when they do in television
tapings act as if you're killing even if
you're not killing make it look like
you're killing fake it til you make it
whoo and that's what television is ooh
you know you you coming from a
perspective of like as if this is like
in some barn someplace and the local
people come to the barn because this is
how they do it this is real but that not
but that might not be entertaining to
the masses okay [ __ ] tough pill to
swallow dude well but you learn you've
learned you've seen it you're just
accepting it for the first time but
you've been fighting this fight your
whole [ __ ] career man this is your
fight your whole career could you be -
could you be nicer could you be a nicer
human being absolutely okay if I look
better hurt and if I look better does it
hurt you know
it hurts your pride but it don't hurt
you yeah I mean I'm learning to less ice
cube and more magic Johnson yeah so or
find someplace in the middle right and
I'm not saying you have to kowtow all
the time I got you know I got you baby
when you get in the car and you don't
know if this is the manager of the place
or not maybe they don't need to be
yelled at because there was traffic and
they were late you know what I mean
obviously does that hurt you you know so
this is what I'm saying this what we're
talking about with you has nothing to do
with your performance on stage but it
might affect how this all coalesces into
the fame and fortune that you want you
know what we got you know what we will
continue this on your podcast yes can I
mention my pocket watch to right now all
right oh [ __ ] we gone too long
relatively new podcast is about a year
and a half old
it's called Spears and Steinberg aka the
Jew in the jerk it's available it who
you and that so you even it's available
to Apple's iTunes or you can go to
Spears Berg or Google Play and actually
don't even worry about this right now
because all this information is gonna be
on this episode ok so right down below
when you look underneath you'll see it I
have all the links and all that stuff
and I will send my people to you yeah
and listen I'm glad you came on we've
talked from over an hour so I don't want
to keep you any more on you know Aaron
I'll be taking up the studio those pills
you saw me taking uh with some dick
pills I'm about to go [ __ ] when I leave
type 2 diabetes yeah well I want you to
be healthy
I'm working on it brother yeah please I
had Billy Gardell on here he had the
same situation really yeah so I need you
to live we all got together look at me
I'm a big fat [ __ ] so we all got
to get our [ __ ] together but listen I'm
glad you came on Thank You me I felt
like again I felt like you were you're a
misunderstood man I see that more now we
don't we've never had this long of a
conversation before and I hope we have
many more conversations like when we
spread the legend brother yeah that
sounds like a dead nigga's ass well wait
a minute
well again I need to hear their side by
the way before we go I've heard stories
about like Dennis Miller I heard the
story about Dennis Miller where he had
worked his ass off his whole career and
now he had a writer and he wanted to be
picked up in a limo right and he was
doing a college and they brought the
volleyball van I would have yelled you
know and he said it was the first time
you said no I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna do it but it was on principle but
all I'm saying is would it have hurt him
to get in that volleyball van no nobody
is Provost sometimes you have to fight
right but you got to pick and choose
those mumm-ra's what I'm saying to you
is I don't think you pick and choose
enough well here's where I made my
choice the last time way back when I
didn't have a writer and I allowed
whoever to pick me up the club did a
clown night before my shows so they sent
the head clown to pick me up at the
airport in his official clown car I said
no more this [ __ ] yeah I need a writer
I'm sitting on squeaky nobody should be
case by case it made for a great show
that night in there I'm sure but enough
of that all right but anyway all right
duck look we're gonna end on him sitting
on clown stuff again you'll have all the
information about riffing with Griffin
remember you could go to my website Erik
refer calm to see my dates also you have
a website yes Aries Spears Spears calm
and all his information is gonna be
below even on the audio and when you're
looking at the audio if you go to the
website of the audio you can you can see
all the information there to guys and
all this preparation ain't fatness it's
hot in here
[Laughter]
believe me this is like I'm moussed as
hell and I don't know why weird a
sweater but anyways I want to thank the
great our re Cerie Aries Aries the
[ __ ] Spears yes Aries no relation to
Britney
okay Aries Spears everybody this has
been rifted with Griffin thank you for
another great episode and I look for me
to go on his episode we gonna continue
this conversation there so thank you for
listening once again this is riffing
with Griffin and now see you on the next
next time you sir thank you